notre page cinéma avec le festival à
cannes il ya les films qui concourt pour
la palme d'or il ya l'écran et les
acteurs les stars mais il ya aussi les
artistes moins connus pour qui le
jugement du public du festival est
important ce public et des de la presse
peut les rendre mondialement célèbre du
jour au lendemain si vous avez voir un
reportage de martine laroche joubert et
de claude sicard au deuxième étage du
palais des festivals le bureau des
comédiens certains appellent ici bureau
des vedettes
le billet d'avion l'hôtel le dîner vaut
mieux être vu ce soir où trouver un
chauffeur un nous appuyons ici aujoulat
nous pour les acteurs et dès l'arrivée à
cannes reçoit l'on vienne de les boules
du teen star le second
avant d'affronter la foule des
photographes
les comédiens viennent souvent ici
prendre des forces il vient un peu
perdus ici incarnent souvent sans par la
foule par le monde
qui est au festival les badauds les
curieux qui font partie également c'est
du festival qui sont importants pour moi
pour nous et donc il faut être un peu
les rassurer s'occuper de rassurer les
comédiens cela peut paraître étrange
mais la plupart craignent le festival la
foule les journalistes attendent avec
angoisse l'accueil de la critique
et s'il n'y a plus de starlettes qui sur
un coup de flash se font à coup de
publicité
il ya de jeunes comédiens pour qui tout
peut se jouer à cannes sur le succès ou
l'échec d'un film ainsi gérard lanvin il
joue dans deux films présentés à cannes
extérieur nuit et une semaine de
vacances
un film de tavernier engagés dans la
compétition officielle bertrand
tavernier aujourd'hui à cannes
c'est même auxerre qui vous fait peur
tous ces gens qui regardent comme sahbi
juge
oui ça fait peur ça fait peur du jeu
culte ans en jarez
de savoir que
tout d'un coup on est on est à quelque
chose qui peut marcher ça fait peur
parce que tout le monde harcèle de
questions ils sont pas toujours malines
toute façon mais se dire ça c'est ça
fait partie du boulot bon la peur quand
même là j'ai peur des angoisses réelle
des acteurs qui par profession sont
hypersensibles
et en ce moment par exemple le festival
s'interroge sans la venue des deux plus
grands timides du cinéma jean luc godard
et jacques dutronc vont-ils venir
affronter l'épreuve de cannes pour
défendre le film qui les réunit le titre
en tout cas est un message sauve qui
peut